[Music]
Canada the country you think about so
little that's it end of sentence but
that's a shame because Canada is an
important country they're our largest
trading partner and the u.s. Canadian
border is the longest in the world
stretching all the way from the coastal
town of who gives a Alaska to the
small fishing village of great whatever
Maine and this makes it a little sad
that you probably don't know
Canada is having a major election soon
and by soon I mean tomorrow which is it
around 50 minutes so by the time we're
done you'll have waited until literally
almost the last moment to learn the
first thing about the Canadian election
an election by the way of historic
proportions today a 78 day campaign
begins by any standards grueling and the
longest on record since the 19th century
okay okay thinking 78 days is a long
campaign is absolutely adorable it's
like a woman who has only ever seen one
penis saying that's the longest one ever
there couldn't possibly be one longer
than that but but I have to say they've
packed a lot into those 78 days
particularly in the local races where
one conservative candidate er Jerry
Bance the owner of an appliance repair
business withdrew for a truly
breathtaking reason well mister bans had
the misfortune of being caught up in a
marketplace investigation into the
ethics of appliance repair businesses
who do house calls Jerry Bance responded
to a service call at a house that was
equipped with hidden cameras as part of
the marketplace investigation and those
cameras caught him urinating in a
homeowner's coffee month dumping the
urine into a kitchen sink giving it a
quick rinse and then putting it back
into the sink oh that's absolutely
disgusting although any surprising
Canada was so shocked about urine in a
mug considering that's exactly what the
bat blue tastes like but amazingly
amazing that's not even the most
surprising scandal in Canada's local
races an NDP candidate in Hamilton
Ontario is apologizing for making a joke
about a Nazi death camp in a 2008
Facebook posting Alex Johnston sent a
picture of an electrified fence post
arsh wits look phallic according to the
Hamilton Spectator Johnston says she did
not know why our switch was until now
wow that is parading two different kinds
of ignorance not knowing what outwits is
and if she thinks that's fanuc not
knowing what a penis looks like and this
kind of makes you wonder who is running
the schools up in Canada Johnston a
social worker by training is the vice
chair of the Hamilton Wentworth history
school board and a school trustee yes
she helped run a school board that would
explain why their history curriculum
includes the textbook poll in 1939 245
things that look like dicks mainly I
know what you're thinking
who cares about Canada's least qualified
school board member and mug dick the
handyman these are just local elections
but the thing is Canadians don't elect
their prime minister directly that's
decided by how many MPs each party gets
so these local races are vital to who
becomes Canada's next leader and the
polls are split between the three major
parties the New Democratic Party or NDP
the Liberal Party and the Conservatives
it's a good old-fashioned Canadian
three-way which is also the sex act in
which three people apologize to each
other so hard they all climax the the
socialist NDP began the election ahead
in the polls but they've since lost
momentum partly because their Leader Tom
Mulcair widely thought to be an
excellent legislator has not been the
most comfortable campaigner here is
Mulcair trying out some slogans health
care child care pharmacare Mulcair
this is what change looks like oh you
are not what change looks like we
understand you're talking about your
policies but still change visually to
not look like Paul Giamatti tunkel
reading a rhyming dictionary as for the
Liberal Party they are currently in the
lead campaigning on a platform of tax
breaks for the middle class and a plan
to run a three-year deficit to boost the
economy and ease the strain of austerity
measures their leader is Justin Trudeau
son or former prime minister Pierre
Trudeau and legendary political figure
in Canada although there are there is
some concern that Justin Trudeau may not
be quite as smart as his father as a
journalist who's covered him concedes
his father was considered sort of
intellectually brilliant smart does he
have that kind of smarts no and himself
but he he has I think other people have
used this word too he has an emotional
intelligence that Pierre Trudeau didn't
have out emotional intelligence that is
the kind of made-up quality you might
find on a report card from a Montessori
School well done Satan you got a
squirrel on emotional intelligence but
on actual intelligence you got a
frowning walrus which is an F that's an
F Zaidan let's make that walrus smile
now now while growing up in the public
eye has given Justin Trudeau name
recognition
it also has had its drawbacks for
instance if you do a google image search
on him you can find every poor fashion
choice that he's ever made from a 90's
boy band member one week before entering
rehab to an LL Bean sweater model who
just underwent a lobotomy - Johnny
Depp's evil twin and it's not just
photos there's also embarrassing videos
out there like this one in which he
explains his party trick of pretending
to fall down a flight of stairs let me
show you how it normally works I put a
person here and I'm passing so it's like
hey how are you
what look look no one is saying that
that is behaviour worthy of a head of
states but you cannot deny that it is
somewhat satisfying to watch a soul
patched man named Justin with a French
accent just fall down some stairs
something there that's good about it and
Trudeau's opponents have used his
lightweight reputation against him by
running ads like these is Justin ready
Justin thinks budgets balance themselves
but Justin hasn't thought that through
Justin doesn't understand the
consequences Justin he's just not ready
now repeatedly calling him Justin is
actually very clever because the more
you say that name the less ready for
office he sounds the name Justin doesn't
convey leadership so much as it conveys
an unwillingness to sit still at the
pediatricians office or ownership of a
system of a down tattoo halfway through
a painful laser removal process those
are the two types of Justin that exist
and just those two but despite these
concerns polls show that Justin is
currently leading incumbent Prime
Minister Stephen Harper a man who thanks
to Canada's lack of tone limits has
already been in office for almost 10
years and while Trudeau has been painted
as a charismatic pretty boy no one has
ever said either of those things about
Stephen Harper just watch him try to
appear relatable something you might not
know about me is that I love movies and
TV shows one of my all-time favorites is
Breaking Bad it's even available on some
online streaming services if you've
never seen
unlove movies and TV shows isn't a
statement that wins over voters it's
what an alien in disguise as a human
tells you all trying to fit in at a
dinner party but but don't don't be
deceived by his bland exterior where
there is banality there is evil
for instance Harper's government has
passed numerous laws weakening Canada's
environmental protections and they've
scaled back health care for some
refugees which a federal court called
cruel and unusual and Harper himself has
taken an extremely strong position on
marijuana
there's just overwhelming and growing
scientific and medical evidence about
the bad long-term effects of marijuana
we've spent a couple of generations
trying to reduce the usage of tobacco in
Canada with a lot of success tobacco is
a product that does a lot of damage
marijuana is infinitely worse are you
high is not worse than tobacco the only
context in which that's true is
aesthetics look at Paul Newman okay now
look at whatever the this is
marijuana is infinitely worse in that
context and that context alone but
Harper's ugliest tendency is perhaps
he's pandering to Islamophobes earlier
this year his government passed a law
called the zero tolerance for barbaric
cultural practices Act stiffening
penalties for things like honor killing
and polygamy despite the fact both those
things were already illegal in Canada
and then a few weeks ago they suggested
a barbaric cultural practices hotline
despite the fact nine-one-one continues
to exist in Canada and this is on top of
the fact that they want banned women
from wearing the niqab while taking the
oath of citizenship a decision that
harper justified to join a
french-language debate like this you
know he'd never tell my daughter that a
woman should cover her face because
she's a woman I would never say that
okay
for a start if Stephen Harper's daughter
is covering her face it's probably
because she understandably does not want
to be seen in public with Stephen
Harper but but but this isn't a
debate about his parenting it's a debate
about forbidding one particular
religious practice and to hear from one
of the women affected by the ban
she did not appreciate it the Canadians
why it's so important to keep your veil
on take me off because they can ad I I
actually chose this country for the
reason is it provides me with the
freedom of my to practice on my religion
as well and Canada's federal courts
actually agreed with her because she
sued Harper's government and won
presumably arguing that if Harper was
happy to let Canadians interact with
their government dressed like this she
should be allowed to wear whatever the
she wants were not enough to make
you hate Stephen Harper there's also the
fact that he has a band a terrible
terrible band
[Applause]
[Music]
that is Stephen Harper murdering Sweet
Caroline with his actual band that he
chose to call the van cats and a parent
play on Van caca to represent 24 Sussex
the name of the Prime Minister's
residence so to recap there Harper's
band's name is not just a shitty pun
it's a shitty French pun on the fact
that he's Prime Minister of Canada that
is the least rock-and-roll thing
imaginable until until you see this
photo of Stephen Harper with the lead
singer of Nickelback and look look I
know it's hard for Americans to care
about this but think of it this way
picture your next-door neighbor you
might not be great friends with her but
you'd be sad if she started dating a
complete and utter well Canada
is America's next-door neighbor and
Stephen Harper is her boyfriend
you know the one she won't split up with
despite the fact he tells her what to
wear and makes her listen to his shitty
shitty band and and I would love to tell
the people of Canada right now to vote
Stephen Harper out of office
unfortunately and this is amazing it's
against Canadian law specifically
section 3 3 1 of the Canada Elections
Act which states no person who does not
reside in Canada shall induce electors
to vote or refrain from voting for a
particular candidate and apparently
anyone found guilty of doing that could
be fined up to $5,000 given a six-month
jail term or both that is a ridiculous
law and I guess what you're saying
Canada is you want to dance is that what
you're saying
bring your best moves because it's
nearly midnight and Johnny's got his
dancing shoes on you think I'm scared of
six months in Canadian prison
what's that six months of living in
Ottawa yes that's right keep yourself
warm with that Ottawa burn and as for
you $5,000 fine I simply can't imagine a
better way to spend 5,000 Canadian
dollars but if telling you not to vote
for Stephen Harper is going to cost me
$5,000 I'm gonna get my money's worth
and I'm gonna do it in the most Canadian
way possible so please come with me
because I'm going to tell you not to
vote for Stephen Harper alongside this
beaver plays Sweet Caroline on the
keyboards and this loose receiving a
colonoscopy
under Canada's fantastic single-payer
health care system and finally with the
help of one of Canada's finest sons Mike
Myers dresses of mountain
[Applause]
full attention gonna go
Oh
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much for doing
this is there anything you'd like to say
yes there's lots I'd like to say I love
Canada but the fact that it has a law
banning outsiders from telling Canadians
how to vote is one of the least Canadian
things possible sure oh and don't vote
for Stephen Harper exactly Stephen
Harper doesn't care about black people
Oh God not again so sorry
what I meant to say was Stephen Harper
doesn't care about Muslim people totally
fair oh yeah there you go I think he
made that pretty clear so please do not
vote for Stephen Harper don't do it
shall we no yeah look at this let's
5,000
[Applause]